c'est pas vraiment sur une rive qu'on se
trouve c'est les pieds dans l'eau les
pieds dans la loire parce que c'est le
paysage qui a bercé l'enfance de manon
un paysage qu'on adore bien sûr donc il
ya de l'eau partout il est aussi plein
de plantes
oui effectivement c'est un jardin que je
voulais richement planté avec une
palette végétale en trois volets donc
horticole une palette végétale horticole
indigènes où on retrouve les populations
de ben ammar et omar et les lézards
basse et pionnière l'ourlet arbustifs et
les arbres en isoler 2 du domaine de la
loire et puis aussi une palette qui se
veut citoyen piraterie ce puisqu'une
qu'elle va accompagner le parcours de
l'eau et du visiteur qui suit cette eau
qui se nettoie ça vous dire que vous
vous êtes penché sur les pouvoirs
extraordinaires de la plante pouvoir de
filtration de purification de l'eau
c'est possible oui c'est possible en
fait le biomimétisme je les ai voulu
m'intéresser à la phytoépuration et au
nettoyage de l'eau par les plantes
effectivement c'est un système
scientifique n'est qu'ici c'est un
jardin petite échelle donc c'est
seulement une illustration de ce
phénomène là d'accord
donc le système fonctionne par une
soulte ration d'abord verticale l'eau
tombe par le dessus ce filtre en passant
dans un substrat
ensuite elle vient faire une pause dans
un bassin de roselières et puis et puis
ensuite à leur revient par les petits
bassins qui illustre la loire et qui
sont l'illustration du phénomène de de
filtration horizontal où l'eau s'écoule
horizontalement pour revenir au point de
départ des plantes qui filtrent l'eau ça
existe en dehors d'un jardin ou d'un
milieu naturel
oui bien sûr il ya énormément de deux
manières de faire et il ya des projets
très concrets qui voit le jour dans des
stations d'épuration pour des lagunages
des piscines naturelles et effectivement
c'est de plus en plus présent vous avez
donc recréer ce paysage c'est un paysage
que vous aimez particulièrement qui vous
passionne qui vous a donné envie d'être
paysagiste oui tout à fait c'est c'est
pour moi
le paysage dans lequel j'ai grandi et
puis aussi c'est c'est la localité du
jardin qui va s'ancrer dans un paysage
et qui va trouver sa légitimité à
exister en s'inspirant de son contexte
large et pour les données pour les
donner encore plus de sens
et j'imagine que le fait d'être ici à
chaumont ça doit être une fierté
particulière avec un jardin qui
ressemble à ce dans quoi vous avez
évolué tout au long de votre vie et
c'est surtout l'occasion de dire que
votre métier y compte il est important
et il offre des solutions
oui tout à fait c'est un médecin
important parce que on va travailler à
différentes échelles s'appelle de la
création du jardin à la maîtrise
d'oeuvre au sens plus large
et puis c'est un travail aussi
d'équipements général ad avec des
architectes des urbanistes et des corps
de métier beaucoup plus technique et
c'est un métier assez peu connue avec
énormément de spécificités et
caractéristiques on peut développer
effectivement par la suite merci
beaucoup manon ce jardin il évolue au
fil du temps cette eau et continue de
passer d'entrelacer tout ça